[Música]
historia teatro y acción el conflicto
vivimos en una sociedad de conflicto y
basta con voltear la mirada alrededor
para darnos cuenta que estas fuerzas que
se contraponen están prácticamente en
todas partes así de caótico y teatral es
nuestro mundo y si no me creen el que
esté libre de conflicto en la sala que
arroje la primera piedra y verá cómo le
va a pegar a alguien y segurito va a
saber de lo que estoy hablando el
conflicto forma parte de nuestra vida
tanto como nuestro deseo de que no
exista pero es inevitable todos los días
vemos que el mundo está en constante
movimiento qué significa esto que va a
generar relaciones y tensiones entre
todos estos personajes que habitamos el
mundo el teatro el teatro solo ha hecho
más que funcionar como un caleidoscopio
de diversos tamaños y formas que le
devuelven a esta sociedad en la que
vivimos algunos fragmentos de su
realidad así que ni inocente ni culpable
se ha convertido en un ritual que
durante los últimos 2500 años se ha
convertido en un espacio donde nos vemos
nos reconocemos para hablar de nosotros
mismos
es muy lógico que en pleno siglo 21 se
pregunte si síguela si sigue valiendo la
pena que sigue existiendo mi respuesta
yo he encontrado un poco en la palabra
drama drama en su origen griego
significa acción la acción eso que
hacemos todos los días aquello que nos
define no solamente a los que hacemos
teatro sino a cualquier persona que
habita en este mundo la acción como algo
que nos permite hacer un puente entre
ese momento que vivimos ahorita y ese
lugar a dónde queremos llegar yo por mi
parte la acción se ha convertido en mi
motivo de vida yo me siento la verdad
muy afortunado de haberme encontrado con
el teatro y sus múltiples conflictos
porque la verdad es que me ha permitido
vivirlo desde diferentes ángulos como
creador la verdad me ha llevado a
lugares insospechados he conocido a
personas que no imaginaba pero sobre
todo lo más importante para mí es que me
ha permitido ver la vida de diferentes
maneras
esto me llevó a pensar en algún momento
si sólo había sido un resultado de la
experiencia artística pero no después me
di cuenta que he tenido la oportunidad
de ver cómo o qué sucede con las
personas cuando el teatro llega a otros
lugares a las escuelas a los centros
comunitarios a las cárceles incluso a
los espacios de trabajo etcétera y es
que hoy más que nunca el teatro deja de
ser algo más que compartir una historia
se convierte en un espacio de
convivencia colectiva un espacio donde
los que se reúnen busca vivir una por
supuesto una experiencia única e
irrepetible donde el actor y el
espectador se encuentran dialogan se
ríen lloran se confrontan pero lo más
más importante es que se permiten vivir
un momento realmente compartir un
momento y díganme la verdad para mí es
díganme si hay algo más humano que eso
que compartir un momento
hace unos diez años nuestra compañía en
un entorno bastante conflictivo en la
ciudad se planteó un par de retos el
primero tenía que ver con nuestro
crecimiento como creadores escénicos el
cual estábamos seguros que si seguíamos
trabajando de una manera constante y
fuerte y sistematizada podríamos lograr
este crecimiento pero el otro gran reto
que nos planteamos tenía que ver con el
vínculo que teníamos hacia nuestra
comunidad y a partir de eso empezó a
darle un sentido especial al nombre de
nuestra compañía que se llama tijuana
hace teatro
desde ahí empezamos un largo camino por
supuesto por demás dramático que además
de hacer creación artística busca hacer
mucho diálogo con el entorno en el que
vivimos que por supuesto sigue sin
escaparse del conflicto yo recuerdo una
vez que una persona en esos momentos
difíciles que vivió tijuana nos
preguntaba si valía la pena seguir
haciendo teatro en un contexto tan
golpeado y en ese momento mi respuesta
más intuitiva que razonada fue un sí que
a través de los años he intentado
aclararme de alguna u otra manera
permítanme compartirles una pequeña
fórmula de algunas piezas teatrales hay
obras que inician cuando hay un
conflicto el cual gracias a la acción de
muchos personajes hacen que vaya
progresando la historia esa historia
crece para bien o para mal y establece
un nuevo orden de las cosas entonces
algo así intentamos hacer nosotros ya
teníamos una sociedad en conflicto que
nos daba pie perfectamente para comenzar
nuestra obra entonces nosotros un poco
como personajes intentamos accionar y
hacer que esa historia progresará para
tratar de establecer un nuevo orden en
nuestro entorno
por supuesto que sonaba tan teatral que
no nos pudimos resistir y seguimos
accionando para hacer progresar esa
historia entonces que hicimos seguimos
haciendo teatro buscando espectadores
con quienes compartir eso que queríamos
decirle al mundo es que queríamos
expresarle entonces lo empezamos a hacer
desde un espacio de creación desde
nuestra trinchera un formato un teatro
de formato íntimo un teatro pequeñito
para 40 personas que desde los últimos
14 años
se ha convertido en nuestra trinchera
para decir las cosas que queremos estas
trincheras que son tan necesarias y que
para nosotros tal vez es un teatro pero
lo mejor para algunos de ustedes es su
propia habitación o su sala de trabajo o
su oficina su salón de clases estas
trincheras o como espacios como este que
nos permiten gestar ideas y compartirlas
con otras personas esas trincheras que
se convierten en el lugar de acción y
aunque a veces también se convierten en
el refugio cuando llegan momentos muy
complicados y miren que hacer teatro
también y tiene no tiene pocos momentos
complicados nosotros lidiamos y luchamos
también con otros rostros del conflicto
con la violencia con la desigualdad
social con la injusticia y con la poca
valoración del trabajo artístico con
discursos que aplauden mucho más la
cantidad que en la calidad y por
supuesto con cosas como decisiones
gubernamentales que con la mano en la
cintura borran de los presupuestos los
rubros de educación y cultura pero bueno
teníamos que seguir accionando estamos
seguros que nuestras acciones podrían
generar nuevos escenarios escenarios
posibles entonces un día se nos ocurre
invitar
diez personas para que vieran teatro con
nosotros durante todo un año diez
personas todos desconocidos de edades y
perfiles muy distintos para que vivieran
esta experiencia que no solamente
consistía en ir a ver teatro sino es
reunirse con nosotros una vez al mes
para platicar de su experiencia que
estaban viviendo en ese entorno
alrededor sí alrededor de un café
invitamos a los teatros para que nos
ayudaran a becar a estas 10 personas
durante todo el año y ahí surgió un
programa que llamamos la escuela
binacional de espectadores un programa
que desde hace 9 años invita a un grupo
de personas para que vean como entre 50
y 60 espectáculos en el transcurso de 10
11 meses de teatro y de danza y después
puedan enriquecer la experiencia a
través de conversaciones con otros
creativos con nosotros o quien quiera
participar en estas reuniones este
espacio se convirtió en un lugar de
diálogo y de apertura es un lugar en el
que todo todos los que participamos
construimos nuevas maneras de convivir
lo cual ha sido muy interesante porque
gracias a este espacio se han roto
barreras de edad de género incluso
geográficas porque desde el 2014 también
cruzamos a la ciudad de san diego para
ver qué sucede con el teatro de aquí de
nuestra ciudad vecina esto sin contar
con la experiencia personal que viven
muchos de los espectadores y que nos
comparten al final del año después
queríamos seguir accionando y el
siguiente paso fue de la mano de los
jóvenes de la ciudad que hicimos un
festival de teatro
preparatorias que funcionará como un
lugar para que los jóvenes pudieran
expresarse entonces se convirtió en un
lugar abierto para que ellos pudieran
expresar sus necesidades sus inquietudes
y donde ellos pudieran decir las cosas a
través de los textos que escribían o que
actúan tiene nueve años este proyecto y
sigue andando y es que sobra decirlo que
el teatro en las escuelas que tienen un
teatro abren las posibilidades para que
estos jóvenes transformen sus propias
relaciones interpersonales me consta lo
he visto entonces todo esto nos permitió
darnos cuenta que se podía vivir en
armonía incluso en etapas tan agudas
como resulta la adolescencia
entonces accionar y trabajar se
convertían en nuestros motores de vida
para seguir haciéndolo
lo he visto cuando maestros toman
técnicas teatrales para incorporarlos a
su práctica docente y ven como el
trabajo con sus alumnos se vuelven más
significativos lo he visto día a día en
la sala de ensayos viendo como los
actores se auto descubren en procesos
que no habían vivido he visto en
comunidades he visto como vecinos se
organizan para
a través del teatro sus inquietudes y
poder canalizar de alguna manera todas
sus necesidades lo he visto en empresas
que en medio de toda su formalidad se
dan una pausa para que puedan a través
del juego encontrar nuevas formas de
convivir o hacer equipos de trabajo y
creo que el ejemplo más importante del
teatro del juego que busca el teatro es
justamente el de los niños porque ellos
comparten en una convivencia sin
prejuicios
todos estos hilos que teje el teatro
están hechos a mano por eso son tan
difíciles de romper así que en este
mundo lleno de conflictos a mí me gusta
ver todavía el teatro como ese espacio
donde todavía poder podemos vernos cara
a cara sin miramientos ahí uno al otro
compartiendo un espacio como lo estamos
haciendo ahorita donde no hay ningún
intermediario ese espacio donde podemos
hacer algo tan históricamente humano
como es compartir el momento entonces
que nos queda ante el conflicto accionar
y trabajar y sobre todo estar muy
conscientes de lo que queremos hacer
porque al final de cuentas ahí
probablemente podamos
encontrar algunas bondades que ofrecen
nuestras profesiones y podamos vivir de
maneras más plenas así que yo los invito
que si en el transcurso de su vida por
ahí se encuentran al teatro tómenlo viva
en un taller vayan al teatro compártalo
con sus familias con sus amigos con sus
colegas hagan suyas las butacas de esta
ciudad porque al final de cuentas todos
formamos parte de ese círculo porque si
bien el teatro no transforma mundos de
un día para otro de manera instantánea
yo sí estoy seguro que siembras semillas
que abren nuevos horizontes más
inclusivos más amplios más diversos pero
lo más más importante mucho más humanos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]